you
you
good morning Millennials sorry we're
about two minutes delayed Heather just
realized she'd never eyebrows off I
didn't even draw them in today I'm
canning you had a traumatic neither so
we just decided to put all three of us
here we're gonna be talking over each
other the whole time Jackie's never been
able to get a word in but that's just a
regular day hey I'm just a toaster
enjoying the show and moderating I'll
hit you guys with the stories and then
get your take on it really like a panel
moderator I just I love a panel a panel
of comedians female comedians unemployed
unemployed unemployed fully unemployed
employed female comedians yes I'm in
supporting other women by the way we are
very supportive here at the morning
shows we support other women wow wow wow
I feel supported as soon as I walked in
this morning or like you made it like we
were like you were really worried about
me last night I just have to say that I
was worried about you but I'm also so
happy for you because I mean I watch all
your stories and I always think you're
so funny but this may be your greatest
work right and for that it's like you
have to spend one night no hotel to
capture the greatest content small price
to pay
listen I've been trying to pitch a
Travel Show for quite some time like the
Heather's hangover show where you just
send me to like crazy place yes I'm just
hungover because you know like when
you're hungover you just have to have
this creature comfort of course so like
do this when I'm hungover throw me and
like a shitty hotel and then we just
watch it all unfold he's never seen at
the hotel I have it but that's the one
with robots right yes and I think that I
need to do a docu-series on you at the
hotel I'm down I'm so down about rocket
ship that shoots your bag to your room
and that seems alarming right I went
there once I'm not gonna walk I wouldn't
say there I saw a movie there they had
like a cinema experience how was it my
allergies were horrible and I had to
leave it was outdoors and I just could
not stop sneezing
not premium enough that's the way and I
just I let the girls know I'm not
contagious I just have a lot of good
like health mental issues going on right
now so if I like like literally
something I blow up in coffee it's just
it is what it is you know it taking off
we apologize to the podcast with Chris
but I think it's more bearable if you're
watching on YouTube if you're listening
as a podcast and you have the bandwidth
to watch on YouTube head over there take
us on we won't disappoint so had that
was in town for the TPG Awards which is
where we hung out two nights ago how did
you think it went I think it went
amazing meet you you know it really made
me realize I think I'm a very savvy
traveler and it just made me realize
like I'm not even as savvy as I thought
no but I
really good about the fact that Delta
SkyMiles won the best overall rewards
program because I know you're a delta
gal - because ATL is all Delta Delta
always I felt good
my grandmother was one of the first
flight attendants and my grandfather I
learned others le I know you say that
already on the show
oh no she told me yeah I heard you're
going around alright well Captain Jack
McMann and then the V stories well so at
the at the event Heather was like Google
Captain Jack man I was like well Sully
was talking and I was like yeah and then
I was like you Google rabbi a fried off
stride look like ara our great-uncle is
very famous rabbi from the Holocaust a
little different but whatever we both
have just sold into an accessories how
do you done 23 MA I haven't because I
think the Illuminati controls all the
results yeah that's definitely true but
I've let go and like I just to confirm
that I'm not adopted yeah I'm I'm
willing to get my DNA to get the body
dress and put a little bit of your own
concerns term are you like you're the
Chloe of the family because of the
adoption yes I guess so just cuz OJ's
your dad yeah but I did 23andme and
Claudia is 99.9% Ashkenazi Jewish so I
was like okay which was a big deal like
in the community yeah I'd only heard of
someone getting up to 98 so in mind come
back 99 percent Wow I was like oh my god
the guy who was 98 was my friend ahna
who has sex he was a dad he was like
telling everyone and then I said Kenny
I'm 99.9 and he like really couldn't
believe it then this [ __ ] so I figured
I'd be like 75% on Eisen and like
wherever I got my red hair from right
there 25% I am 100% in Ashkenazi Jewish
100% I don't even as a Gentile I don't
even know how to absorb this amount of
epicness as soon as they get it's really
crazy I never like thought of myself
gladion not one of our great great great
great great great great great great had
like a secret affair with a Gentile
yeah or a nun secret affair where
someone can no one converted right blood
lines are straight down that's why from
the pale of solidus Madame Madame
so you're somebody on your side that
your family is recessive had a recessive
redhead yeah no we believe it was our
dad's dad right well yeah everyone likes
to take credit for it honestly it's like
Oh Mike grandfather had it in his youth
actually I had it too so I think I gave
it you I think what am i girlfriend she
has the most beautiful baby on the
planet and she
husband her husband was Mexican she is
like a French American my like French
Cajun
she sounds gorgeous she owns clothing
companies show your muumuu and sure baby
Magnolia is a most beautiful baby but
she has red hair and green eyes Wow and
so they think it's actually a recessive
gene on the Mexican side so you never
think there's right blue line or green
eye thing but then your son has red hair
so it is in your DNA but so that's the
thing he's technically adopted so the
genes they don't align but you never
know you never know I mean it feels like
he came from my own vagina but right
where do you see in the documentary
three identical strangers of course I
did dude because they played on Delta
first I watched on though also when I
watched that I thought okay I have a lot
of people that look like me I think I
just one of those very familiar faces my
too but I legit I had a friend who was
at a concert and she turned around once
and she thought it was me and it was a
another girl she took a photo and this
girl this was years ago she's like I
don't know if I saw the manager posting
our answer yeah and literally it's like
she was like no you are my friend
Heather and it was a creepiest thing
ever she was I got an Eagles concert
people wise agency maybe I was you know
I'm technically Jewish suppose you wanna
hear something crazy
yeah Ben's mom is adopted from the Lummi
spies agency and she was born in the
same month as the three triplets and her
birth mom and the triplets birth mom
knew each other so she was in it now
we're convinced because they're still
you know the medical records are sealed
they are still a bunch of twins who
haven't been discussing the sets of twin
sets this means that they didn't know
that they have twins and we think Ben's
mom is one of them we're recording a
patreon episode with you and we're gonna
ask her all because she was adopted into
a family with one other sibling for that
was not adopted from we live same month
same gear like same head doctors in
place and she says she does have vivid
memories of people coming to her house
and documenting like and filming well
for the first time of my life I've been
speechless twice today
I know Wow I know and it's so crazy and
it's like she's as excited as we are to
like investigate yeah Judis woman alive
like she's the key part lifted we have
to go back to her like the house where
she grew up and like get the files well
I love a good investigation
and then also we need to storm the
Bastille at Yale and have them open up
the records that's what's the craziest
part that like we're in the modern era
and you're protecting monsters monsters
Mengele vibe monsters and like they're
pretty much dead so who are you
protecting let these people know mm-hmm
crazy it's like we can all agree that
what happened in the past
and wasn't even that far nice but
whatever in the past was atrocious but
like make right now make it right make
it right now
speaking of making right I would like to
do a deep dive into your treacherous
evening and while I am sorry that that
that happened you I'm really excited to
talk about it so I'm like kind of happy
that it happened yes and we have to
apologize for the role that we endeavor
to leave because I do feel responsible
that we chose this morning so how do you
have a show because you had to stay in
the city here's the thing I don't feel
refreshed I forgot to put my eyebrows on
because if you two slits so okay so
basically what happened was like we are
very loyal to that the beautiful
Thompson hotel the Thompson is great
they're the best ecology yeah great
they're great but something messed up
with our reservations so we thought we
were booked through the weekend but
actually everything in New York last
night was oversold so we were like oh
that's fine we'll find another place
just for the evening so my boyfriend
Jeff went on the hotels tonight Italian
stereotype so it was a great app yeah
which I feel like bad about the app but
I think what they did was full false
advertisement I know that I like bougie
things but I also would like surf camp
in San Diego and like used to live it
sleeping like her sleeping bag bougie
about Santiago this was a bougie we
would literally sleep in a tent in the
trailer park like I am like an outdoorsy
girl I can rough it right so yeah really
good so last yesterday Jeff got all
flustered he's like all right let's just
find somewhere quick whatever we went on
the app and everything in New York
because the first two weeks in December
everything is like quadruple the holiday
season yes apparently it's the shoppers
week also you don't go online and shop
you have to come to New York to shop get
at it's like an expense you should just
spend that money on the gifts and paying
a markup online
wait where do all these people have all
this money to come to New York and
$2,000 I know hotel room that costs $200
but I have so many questions after my
experience last night so we ended up
Jephthah flustered I should have booked
it I should have taken the rains don't
send a man
to do a woman's job totally and truly
you know travel is like that's where we
thrive yes except for the points guy
except for the points guy yeah well you
know he's thriving yeah okay so we ended
up looking at the RO New York City okay
dumpster fire right off Ethan ooh [ __ ]
show as soon as we pulled up I should
have known there was like a thousand
tourists coming out and I was like this
is it this is where we die thought it
wouldn't be that bad it's still Japanese
EPS spending $500 which now of course
people that message give me like Heather
that room is usually like 90 bucks I was
like are you kidding me so inflation
supply and demand I don't have a finance
degree but it's a real thing
of course opportunity costs yes so he
gets so tile room is 500 bucks we check
our bags I'm like oh my god I'm
panicking sure enough an hour later as
we're sitting and having lunch
it's down to like 200 so I call and they
won't price-match me they won't Bryce
check I'm like this is some [ __ ]
[ __ ] stains on the sheets the alarm
was going off at 8:00 a.m. this morning
in like literally they're like do not be
alarmed
there is no fire you do not have to like
run for the you know yeah literally run
for the hills
oh so I'm laying in bed last night I
literally cannot even get comfortable
and I can smell menthol cigarettes you
know the like yes it's a difference
between a regular cigarette and a
menthol it's spicy and I'm never that
[ __ ] to call down but I was like no I'm
just mean everything like I need a
doctor ever you did so last night I call
them and I'm like somebody is smoking on
this floor is this a smoking floor
they're like absolutely not we're
sending security up literally Jeff heads
I was like dying of emphysema halfway
through the night and I thought a trike
Austin's Halloween but he was actually
dying so when the alarms going off about
like the fire this morning of course I'm
thinking well you know some menthol
Sigma and burnt it down exactly yeah
he put it in the vent and I left before
Jeff today and I looked at him and I was
like please get out of this hotel as
quickly as possible then we pull back
the sheets cuz I'm like you know
throwing my bag literally stains we
didn't see them last night because
everybody was messaging me to check for
the bedbugs so I checked for the back
bugs didn't see me there were stains I
put them on my Instagram I am shook that
is so crazy because regardless of how
thing
you're not fancy hotel is the bare
minimum is just like a change of sheets
from the person before you cleanliness
cleanliness listen you can be a snob all
day long I'm not trying to be a snob but
I just expect if you're gonna pay a
premium rate of $500 for a hotel room it
better have at least clean sheets right
and then you've got some messages from
other people who have seen their saying
one that sometimes one time someone has
used shampooing Edition er yes that is
so vile one person works for the Maury
show and that's where they put up their
guests who are prostitutes of cars
waiting for drug dealers yeah it's wild
but you were originally at the Conrad
for the TV G award yes the TPG Awards
was beautiful I mean iid have fun yeah I
mean really truly this is how my life
goes though I have like a really
glamorous yes beautiful moment and then
God's just like you know what Heather
you got too cute for too quick and then
he just brings me right back down to New
York City yeah and that's I mean a did
bring premium content of Christ may have
to like take off the top layer of my
skin now cuz I'm starting to itch you
know salt scrub why do I need a spot up
yeah so this just now confirms me in
Jackie's theory that the the TPG awards
were amazing but no but the three of us
need to get together and do another sort
of award to just start like a website
like the points got accomplished yeah
the opposite for like the shittiest
worst terrible customer service horrible
to avoid at all cost will make a website
podcast a web show it'll be called the
stories the tragedies the travel Rousey
is s I love that I'll use Squarespace
and now make a website because I don't
really know how to make a website but
Squarespace you could make a website
domain email blasts all that [ __ ] I'm
getting my marketing to get their
underwear space the points girls and you
can too if you want to make a website on
Squarespace head to squarespace.com
slash toast for a free trial and when
you're ready to launch use the offer
code toast to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or a domain I mean
I use Squarespace for like a bunch I'm
always making websites like up in the
middle that I we can swap site right and
I'm working on it I made my website with
them and then you know and then I
realized why I don't know why I have a
website you don't I mean but I like felt
like I needed one yeah I was like I'm a
business yeah the only thing they need a
website and then when someone asks you
why do you have a website you really
can't but it's also later
wants to find Heather for something yeah
and I got a person is like well what's
her deal you send the website you need a
website everyone yeah everyone needs a
web
yeah like NGO website I don't know if I
kept my domain name so I think I need a
OK Go Daddy for that use come toast I
will use coke toast and get my website
back and running and then I'm just gonna
have an entire the front page is gonna
be a yelp review of the road my son
Heather McMahon calm go straight
redirect it to the Yelp yeah Remiel
review here's the thing - and tell me if
I'm like if I do the right thing I
posted the photos of the stains and I
tagged a minute and I'm really I have
worked in customer service you have to
realize I've worked in so many
restaurants my entire family work for
the airlines like I understand
hospitality that is why I have zero
tolerance for the film you did the right
thing it's not like you got there and it
was janky and so you tagged them for
being janky like you gave them so many
chances and that was the last straw
and at the very restaurant though it's
not every day you get to stay in a hotel
room that has a restaurant how
prestigious
the craziest part you know and the rest
it was so funny you were being so funny
honestly moments like that like when
you're at your lowest are the best
creatively a really and truly and it
really tests your relationship and if
you can get that together you can really
get through anything like IKEA see you
know someone at their absolute worst I
Jeff looked at me this morning and he
said he was like I'm so sorry and like
he I was like we could have moved to a
different hotel at any moment he was so
stubborn but he was so stubborn he's an
Italian from New York he was like yeah
no I'm gonna let them know about it
tomorrow and I'm like why don't we let
them know from the comfort of the
ritz-carlton tonight baby you know and
Jeff is Jeff easily could've person to
where like if he needs to like [ __ ]
about something like if we you know you
never send him to the front desk because
he like passive-aggressively money under
incest where I'm like make my contact
with the person jack-high me him I know
it's not your fault you didn't
personally stain my sheets but then we
have a conversation about how to rectify
the situation so funny accepts me and
been like I'm against it because I'm
like let me talk but really Benz much
better I'm like yeah that's fine [ __ ]
[ __ ] like yeah yeah like you know miss
if we can actually just coordinate some
other plan now I'm just like that let me
take it and I'm just like I get though I
get it's the worst deal yeah I'm so mean
Benes and I'm like that I got this right
and then you mumble under your breath
it's like his passive aggressiveness
it's just like to another level I'm like
you are not helping me might tell it's
like literally saying as you walk off
like I hope this plays and then the fire
alarm yeah and then I'm like that seemed
like we had such chicken footage oh
we're sorry for your child but we're
glad you're here though and we're glad
you're here I just got a call my
dermatologist and tell her I'll see you
on Monday
well Heather is here finally and we are
here to deliver the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast and there's some rather chelating
stories today rather titillating okay
first story two names that I never
thought I'd say in the same sentence
Natalie Portman apologizes again -
Jessica season oh my gosh I'm stressed
out already oh do you guys know this
story I saw Jessica Simpson's Instagram
post but I didn't know what prompted
okay yeah I couldn't figure that there's
the story Natalie Portman is following
up on her original explanation of her
comments about Jessica Simpson with a
direct apology quote thank you for your
words okay they skipped around here
anyway if I start from the beginning
what is now nicely yeah okay Natalie
comment Natalie Portman made a comment
about Jessica Simpson being in a bikini
and how she was also like a virgin at
the time in the 90s in the 90s she was
photographed in the bikini and it was
also saying she was their Jenin now the
department thinks she can't do both
yes and then Jessica Simpson put out a
very well written statement I think I'm
gonna actually read it verbatim ladies
just instagrammed calm shutting down
right now Jackie I agreed that it was a
well written statement but the red and
black motif was weird like yes like I
was like she went out of her way to put
like casino colors in her statement and
I thought that was an interesting
aesthetic choice I agree but I think she
wanted just to be taken seriously okay
mmm and he's also like the colors of
virginity like red really I don't know
red is a color of blood when you break
your virginity so it's all come off that
cherry okay this is what she said at
Natalie Portman I was disappointed this
morning but the bread that I confused
you by wearing a bikini and a published
photo taken of me when I was still a
virgin in 1999 as public figures we both
know our image is not totally in our
control at all times and that the
industry we work in often tries to
define us in boxes in however I was
taught to be my
Talton honor the different ways all
women express themselves which is why I
believe then and I believe now that
being sexy and bikini and being proud of
my body are not synonymous with having
sex
I've always embraced being a role model
to all women and to let them know that
they can look however they want wear
whatever they want and have sex or not
have sex with whomever they want the
power lies within us as individuals I
have made it my practice to not shame
other women for their choices in this
era of time's up and all the great work
you have done for women I encourage you
to do the same I thought that was such a
beautiful statement and I agree ho what
are we talking about right yes and
brother where did Natalie probably make
these initial comments why did she why
she covered up her and also why's
Natalie Portman's still thinking about a
photo of Jessica Simpson in a bikini
from the 90s right I don't know from the
GQ shoot where she looks so bangin so I
always think about like when I think of
Jessica Simpson my mind immediately goes
to that Daisy Duke
oh shoot with a little underwear denim
and underwear she looks so great and I
was like the best she ever looked yeah
so I understand Natalie Portman I just
you know I think I would feel a lot
better if I knew what exact oh they were
referring to you know yeah the whole
shoot was in a set I don't know but it
the interview she said that she was
confused as a teenager while she was a
teenager by a photo of the singer in a
sexy bikini accompanied by an article
saying she was a virgin and then so in
Natalie Portman's apology she also tried
to lay blame the media for putting those
two things next to each other right and
not Jessica so I guess the point in the
original interview was like as a woman
growing up I was given false media like
yes I [ __ ] with Natalie Portman like she
really pisses me off I don't [ __ ] with
her either I'm team Jessica Simpson like
no matter what the argument even was but
she's also right well I'm team Jessica
Simpson because we had the same birthday
and like I've always felt this like
connection to her and when she was like
at her peak and like birthday buddies
like was a thing I was like yes just
since it's my birthday buddy and like
everyone was always jealous of me and I
don't [ __ ] with Natalie Portman and you
dink like I died for her just because
she's like a fellow Jewish girl from
Israel born in his row but like I think
she's so entitled and annoying and like
if I see her what Dior commercial
running out of her wedding in a big
dress and then getting into a helicopter
one more [ __ ] time I'm gonna kill
someone probably her I love Natalie
Portman on the opposite but I love Jay
simps because she makes a solid wedge
well so yeah when I was in college my
feet were actually a size bigger there I
was an 11 I'm a 10
which I don't I didn't know that your
feet could shrink necessarily so I would
literally I would I could only wear
Jessica Simpson's wedges so I buy
Jessica's [ __ ] because she sells at Lord
and Taylor which our favorite show our
favorite or ever and I think that her
business is amazing I love that she
sells real close to real people and I
just love her and I love that like she
was a pop star and like literally like
wasn't good at it and just made a
billion-dollar Empire hated only flies
private from a [ __ ] line at Kohl's
and Macy's I just love her for that and
her [ __ ] is good and I own a pair of
wedges you actually more of like a
platform chunky heel yeah I'm into that
yeah and I have a kimono and like a
beach thing I just love her so I will
always defend her but Natalie Portman is
always like out here like calling people
out for their [ __ ] like she need to be
called out that was me I totally agree
I'm glad she would say that I'm glad she
apologized I'm sure they're fine they're
cool now so I'm cool with both of them
but I'm glad someone just like called
her out she's an intimidating person to
take on especially if you're Jessica
Simpson and people think you're just
like trash you know they don't think I'm
a blonde with big titties you know and
the stereotypes at some days I'm like
you know enough with the hate crimes
against me I'm in college
I have a degree from the University of
Mississippi in theater arts do you
really yeah what did you learn in
theater arts class uh you know I learned
nothing I learned that you got to get
out there and hustle you know I went
back and I spoke to like me like the
theater department and that's such an
honor I'm going back to my high school
on Thursday oh well I'm doing there like
would you moderate the panel with the
other careers I'm like ok so my career
is not good enough to be on the panel
I'm moderating it excuse me justice for
moderators justice moderate but who's on
the panel maybe with some beads of hedge
funds and then you should just be happy
these wipers I think I'm very
accomplished like sort of no but sir
you're up on the stage take the win I
don't know I just like felt this
prestige honor and they were like would
you and I'm like moderate and I was like
oh okay I think being a moderator is
grossly underrated like you get as much
talking time if not more and you don't
have to like you don't get one you don't
get more we don't have to think on your
feet
that's very point I'm loving this class
I'm full this morning I came in class
I'm not even on the table you know what
I mean but
love it our positive energy well what I
I was terrible at going back and
speaking I spoke to my high school and I
spoke to the theater department because
literally I was like in such a better
place in my career I think oh you want
to be an actor good luck and like I
can't look like you better learn how to
like wait tables and hustle and
literally I remember what my professors
like white like please shut it down
legit I told these kids that's like
thank you here it's not gonna get you
anywhere you better figure out how to do
YouTube and like make one I mean by the
way and Jackie always says this like
there are people who are unbelievably
talented like you may not know there's
like I have like one of the best voices
I spent oh you do I know you can
oh yeah yeah oh yeah core support it's
like what am I out here trying to be a
singer like no not show you be not in
that everyone who has a talent like
needs to pursue that talent full-time
right sometimes it's just like Jackie
says like a party trick
right so sometimes kids especially those
who want to go into acting in theatre
like they need a good kick in the ass
right they think they're the most
special and they're the most yeah and
they're gonna graduate from theater
school and become Natalie Portman right
and they're not and so I think here
we're doing them a really good like a
civil service and I grew up with like
the parents where my parents like it I
wasn't great at soccer and my mom was
like this is not your sport figure it
out I would come off the stage am I like
mom would have notes for me for my
performances in like the high school
musical do you feel me yes
so I come from a very little realistic
critical family where it's like hustle
hard rise & grind you know I hate people
the rising cried I like to rise and
relax no I like I don't even write just
chill I'd roll in relax
rollin grind and we could eat do you
know my favorite story that you've ever
told me was about when you join the
sorority and the first make sure that
you how do you know this is right you
have to hear them missed out on so much
because you were busy you tell them the
story of them yeah yeah okay so when I
joined I'm Chelsea I'm at the University
of Mississippi
I'm like obviously I did not notice gave
myself in universe a Mississippi Ole
Miss Ole Miss okay I just like to say
the University did you do the bell the
bell Oh what are you talking about the
Bell this girl at my show literally in
Alabama she was like will you ring this
like cowbell oh that's Mississippi State
oh I knew I did what I was doing it
upside down but
were there when Michael Oher was there I
wasn't Michael Oher was there you guys
going to eat or anything we did not go
on a date although you know he wasn't
dating Jeff he's totally my type
honestly like the offensive lineman like
like hot black dude it's like really and
truly like that's who's into me and it's
it you know we're doing our thing like
okay Mississippi so I joined the
sorority and our first mixer or we call
it yeah our first mixer was bikers and
maids well I thought it was like Lance
Armstrong Tour de France like bikers so
I show up on the bus with this like hot
fraternity guys and I show up full span
like Illman on LIVESTRONG bracelets and
everybody's in like Hells Angels like
you know fringe leather like sexy little
miniskirts and I get on in a bike wait
did I oh my god that is so funny did you
say and sorry for all throughout college
yeah I'm not a smarty God but I had said
she loved it I loved it it was so much
fun I had the best four years of my life
really how do you feel about Harvard's
crackdown on single sex clubs there they
just in two store that if you're in a
single sex club like a frat or sorority
that you can't be like captain of any
clothes jeans can't write you
recommendations they're really why
trying to discourage people from having
same sex clubs on campus
no that is such [ __ ] and I hate when
people say like my sorority sisters were
not mean you know we did so much charity
work we like we're friends with
everybody like we had the most diverse
group of friends I hate that bull show
and be like oh if you're in a sorority
you're like a rich brat no we didn't
like I met some of my best friends ever
and there's a lot of good guys and
fraternities yeah there's small-minded
people or there's like you know whatever
it's like sticks up people's ass yeah
but that didn't happen at my school but
if it did I didn't endorse it and I
don't condone it but they are basically
saying like we don't think there should
be anything it's based off the premise
that like you shouldn't be separated by
gender and like while I do agree why
don't why can't there be single sex
sororities and then also some co-ed and
some like non gender or just criminal or
why make less why can't we have a girls
club though you
me I can't sit around with y'all we
can't shoot the [ __ ] and just wear some
letters and like have like a Widow's we
gotta get you your letters we have we're
TMT sorority and we have yeah yeah I
hate that if I want out of a club with
you know
however with you everywhere I should be
able to do that agreed great no boys
allowed next to a club really want me to
talk about this Katy Perry just paid a
lot of money to go on a date with
Orlando Bloom after slitting a Katy
Perry in Orlando at us on our toes from
the start okay marie-claire calm down
the first article came up was Marie
Claire I'm like we've never even knew
I'd mentioned the Marie Claire as a
publication so I thought it'd be I
thought the same but they clearly need
to like get the time the view time on
their page is up because they're going
through a history of their relationship
I need you know at the end um this was
part of an auction Katy Perry surprised
fans this week at the one love Malibu
charity show
supporting relief efforts from the wooly
flag fire when she outbid fans to buy a
date with her boyfriend for $50,000 oh
that's cute though this man that I am
dating in totally loving respect he is
literally a Malibu og Katy's reported to
explain of her boyfriend while putting
him up for auction according to The
Hollywood Reporter that also means that
when you're on a motorcycle with him you
were holding him in a way that I am not
excited about you are holding his pecs
and his six-pack and it's so glorious
you get to see Aaron his brown eyes oh
it's gorgeous so basically this girl
from the audience is like a huge Katy
Perry fan auctioning off
$20,000 a bit yeah and she was about to
get it and Katy Perry was like not thank
you [ __ ]
50 grand and she's getting so much [ __ ]
for it people are saying like because
everyone hates Katy Perry and I'm
literally the first person to say
something negative about Katy Perry but
I think this is kind of cute and she
donated more money to relief efforts
like what's everyone's [ __ ] problem
yeah I say go for it if you know what if
we ever put the Italian stallion up for
auction
right I am the only woman who's allowed
to rub my claws through his chest like
I'm sorry if he's up for auction and you
have a spare 50 grand it's like of
course I'm gonna buy my baby back it
didn't win I thought it was like kind of
cute when I heard it and I was like I
didn't know the outrage and it's like
there's so many things Katy Perry tells
like there was no outrage for her bone
Appetit video when there really should
have been and the lyrics to that song
but no now we're bashing her for doing
charitable work it's like I think she's
really trying to get back in the good
graces of America like she knows she
became an half
she's working on growing out her hair
and fixing it and I'm here for it and
I'm trying to help her and I think this
was a cute thing to do and I'm not mad
about it whatsoever and I'm the first
person to attack her it's a good cause
and she put on this event yes so I'm
fine
set it down Marie Claire try to sound
like I've been seeing so many people on
Instagram like making videos about her
and I'm like really this is one work
they're taking up in arms I wanted to
take up in arms when they were needing
her like dough yeah anything with a kid
yes thank you she's still with Orlando
mmm nice cute you ever see those
pictures of him naked on the paddleboard
did either of you know no but can you
soon they were photographed like on a
nude beach paddleboarding and he's just
like on his knees like sitting up
paddleboarding with his [ __ ] dog
falling out and it's you know it's
interesting I think everyone should take
a look you know I love Jeff with all my
heart but I never want to see a
paddleboard because whatever we go to
the Turks and Caicos and he tries the
paddleboard it's it's the most part of a
heavy and his head's big so it's like a
thing it's balancing I don't need to see
that with his getting on the paddleboard
yeah the hardest fredom I've
paddleboarded once in the hitchens in
this Bay that's horrible they have the
worst most choppy waters so it wasn't in
the ocean it was in a bay basically like
a lake it was liked by my friend Leila's
house it was literally just like a
circular and you know water in New York
is like brown and gross and I was just
so afraid of falling off those weird
beaches there are eight girls on four
paddle boards and it was really heavy
back then so it's usually like chew on a
paddle but it was me and my friend
Alicia who Alicia of all my friends is
just like the least coordinate when it
comes to sports and athleticism and we
got stranded in the middle and like oh
that's the last time I'll ever go
paddleboarding in my entire life because
I was so afraid of the weight
distribution because I made so much more
than her that like I was afraid of being
the one to tip us over you know so I
just sat the whole time very safe yeah
yeah you can sit that's nice like it
doesn't have to be and if someone's
paddling behind you it's just it's very
uneven the paddleboard like that you
lean a little right and you get one wake
get down down it's not something I'm
ever interested in like taking up as a
hobby I'm much more of a jet ski kind of
gal and trying to actually get on the
board now that I think about the gorl
and they're like pushing his junk on the
board like you have to it's like I mean
it's a surfboard you know you got to
like squeeze you're on and then you
gotta somehow lift up no
look at the pictures you guys I don't
participate in looking at celebrity nude
photos but why he was out in public
that's true but he probably didn't think
they were paparazzi around I feel like
he's very European and he didn't really
care
late in America it's like nude photos
such an invasion of privacy in Europe
they're like yeah we go to the beach
here naked I went to a beach in Europe
not even a nude beach and everyone was
nude and it was it was shocked did you
get a nude no I didn't I
topless when I'm in Europe all the time
do you I love to feel the warm fuzzies
on my areolas no because I put the crane
yeah a credible Oh also I've never been
too new to be fitted in to Miami and
like one in every 100 girls in Miami has
their tits out like on the beach and I
remember the first time me and Ben were
in Miami and there was a girl with the
most like perfect beautiful breasts like
perky teardrop very real but very secure
in their status yeah and they were out
and I was like I couldn't stop staring
and I'm like been stopped looking but I
literally couldn't stop staring they
were the like if I ever went to a doctor
and I wanted boobs I'd be like mental
image right but this girl I want that I
know where one pieces to it's not as
glamorous you know like you kind of like
pull down the top like all right
grandmas when the mail you know it's not
like I like take off my little bikini
top right God one pieces came back in
style
I have a long torso and I feel like when
you have big boobs it's like a one-piece
is so much better just because it like
holds everything up it's like it's like
one suction thing when you wear like but
you're so nice I don't have I don't have
a torso right I just don't hide like
yeah yeah yeah yeah but I'm fine with
Katy Perry's but all it's trying to say
which is why I want to talk about it oh
she's great actually kate harris i has
some of the best breasts ever i came
very real like cos a mushy yeah I look
beautiful they are
okay next Tori Kylie Jenner just
responding to those fake Travis Scott
cheating pictures and she's not thrilled
so this was crazy some pictures of what
looks like Travis Scott making out with
a girl surfaced and then at first people
said it was shot during his music video
but now it turns out it was an elaborate
prank by YouTube people who did the
Justin Bieber one I don't know except
these people are starting to [ __ ]
annoy me yeah where did they photoshop
know he'd a got a guy who looked just
like Travis Scott could do the same hair
and the picture the girls face was in
front
picture look so it's like you just see
his hair that's Travis Scott so I
related an Instagram story and she said
idk if this is really a social
experiment to some people but you're
messing with real people real
relationships real family I'm happy my
relationship is strong because this is
getting out of hand the internet scares
me sometimes for real but we all needed
it too yet Kim tweeted I hate that I'm
bringing attention to this but this is
absolutely disgusting that you would
find this funny to mess with Travis and
Kylie who just started a family together
this is really damaging to relationships
families and it's just so wrong and then
Khloe said people are absolutely
discussing the mind games this would do
to somebody that is so completely not
okay this person should be so ashamed of
themselves
what filth so this really reminded me of
the Jessica birthing no of Elle magazine
putting out a tweet with an article
Kim and Kanye had it confirmed getting
divorce and you clicked it it was like
register to vote and I was like oh damn
okay it's definitely important to
register to vote but like it's not nice
to play with like the editorial
narrative of people's lives and they
would only do this to the Kardashians
because nobody respects them and this is
perfect like this is exact more proof
that nobody respects the Kardashians I
thought this was so [ __ ] up and then
you can't even compare it to the Justin
Bieber thing because what they did with
Justin Bieber was like he eats burritos
weird that's not like a disparaging
rumor and they Justin Bieber thing
actually is an interesting social
experiment that all media outlets just
immediately picked it up do you didn't
care to verify it and just one want to
talk about how Justin Bieber eats Abril
I actually thought that that was like a
prank well done innovative state and
made everyone look moronic and like we
care about the dumbest [ __ ] but first of
all if this were true about Travis and
Kylie we would care and we do deserve to
you we're invested in their relationship
but what social experiment are you
trying to prove like I don't know that
what happens when a picture like this
comes out
yeah that's disgusting honestly that's
just are we that bored
bruh Erica is giving all we truly that
bored don't you have to like go pay your
taxes I don't know pick up your kids
from school this [ __ ] pisses me off
can't we also just let sleeping dogs lie
the Justin Bieber experiment was a great
success and like why didn't have to
recreate the magic like why can't
anything just be good and move on no now
we have to beat this joke to a pulp I
agree I also want to talk about Chavez
and Kylie for a second cuz something
I've been thinking about them he calls
her his wife all the time she calls him
her husband no
ever questions it then she puts on her
Instagram story a picture of them with
the ring emoji and then enews like posts
it who say their engagement are they
getting married but it's like I think
they are married as they mustered to
some sort of Sybil literally could get
on stage and say Kylie Jenner is my wife
no one reports it she posts a ring emoji
what does it mean right like they're
telling us I think I'm one of his tour
stops in like Oklahoma they got married
TMZ like doesn't have moles there and
they can't find the court documents yeah
you can't find the court documents I'm
just like I live for Kylie's private
life being so private like I'm just
obsessed third the only reason I think
they may not be married is because
homegirl is so [ __ ] rich and he's
rich to be like she's another level of
billionaire status and I don't think
she'd just be so quick to like join into
a conjoined you know community property
marriage right maybe they got married in
the state where that's not the law like
so they definitely didn't get married in
California because then it is community
property maybe they went to a state with
like stricter laws and she's protected
maybe and she just wants like to be a
full family she's a baby she's a baby
and like all she wants us to have like a
pure family because she came from like a
family that like is sometimes disgusting
but her family is controversial but they
really are at the definition of family
like be sad for Rob you know I watch the
Kardashians I'm and I always think I'm
like my sister tonight I think are close
when I'm like my sister would throw me
in front of a bus the way Kim did
Courtney any day of the week and then
come back and she wouldn't apologize
like we have a great relationship but my
sister kind of person who just doesn't
apologize you know and like my sister
could do something terrible and I didn't
apologizing for it and I crying you
don't mean but that's really family like
that just move on and they they're
really a testament and I think most of
their success can be attributed to the
fact that they are this unit and they
are like but you it is for what's where
it's like a locked
fortress a fortress know like what's
like a classic fort that's like 40 knots
thank you they are Fort Knox like no
one's getting in believe me I've tried
when you really think about it - for
being such a public family I mean they
have had everything happened to me
everything nearly everything everything
even things that aren't on the list of
like the bad things that happened to be
yeah like they've gone through every
single thing like life-changing robbery
Caitlyn transitioning cancer CC yeah
Lamar OD Ames everything
so many fidelity yeah crate that you
block China of it all where she been
that's what I was saying cuz we okay so
we have a basket here let me show you
this is our basket of people that we
China me that we just can't [ __ ] talk
about anymore obviously started by black
China we've been talking we were talking
about her every day she and Rob did this
she yeah and we just couldn't [ __ ]
taking any more smooth said we're gonna
try to hurt we're never gonna talk about
her again and then a bunch of people
ended up coming on Nelson news to China
um but I think that could start talking
about black China again like I kind of
miss her I just want an update
yeah what did she put the book [ __ ]
house dream dreams of cutie dreams of
cutie dream of spending a lot of time
with the Kardashians eye custody wise
where's Rob that's what we said
yesterday like I heard he's coming back
in he's skinny but also I heard that
from like a very unreliable people on
Facebook I I want Rob to win ID me too
I want Rob I want him to be the brother
that they all need him to be I just I I
at the end of the day I get angry and
I'm like Rob get out of bed get your
[ __ ] together but then I'm also like
rising crying cries and Roy drop old Rob
got a rolling grind yeah Rob's gonna
rise a guy
oh it's 11:11 make a wish that was show
Network show Network show Network show
Network show Network show Nozomi
what's your wish for 11:11 literally the
exact same so the Travel Show what was
would you the name for it I don't know
maybe like Heather's hangover hour or
you know honestly that's an amazing
prime minister show there are not enough
travel shows that are like everything's
you know it's aspirational but what
about like realistic right hungover like
you're out in a pub in Amsterdam yeah
wake up the next morning in a hostel
when you have to be out by 11 a.m.
oh my god you carved out hey can I get a
late check-out thank you yes 11:30 yeah
they're like you can hang out in your
bunk bed in the room of 35 people till
1104 restaurants restaurant oh you guys
do with tchotchkes you know I had the
charts key challenge um yes and I love
the chachi challenge and it's like a
thought that I've always had but haven't
been able to articulate it's like right
what does this mean this means nothing
I'll go to someone's house and see like
something on the wall I'm like that
doesn't mean anything
also I didn't know that's how you spell
chachki that is I use mantra I thought
it was like she ch cha chaa ch
kie chachki and and judge he's a Yiddish
Yiddish
okay that's why thought yeah cuz my mom
it's a Jewish descent you are honoring a
language thank you and your history yes
and then in from the south we would call
it a nickname yes yes so a lot of people
were like what's a tchotchke and i'm
like it's a knick-knack honey don't you
worry black it's another word for
nickname yeah that's it's just you know
why do we need another sign that says
gather here Live Love Laugh yeah John
talk to me till I've had my [ __ ] like
I'm not gonna talk to you any we do it
I'm gonna get what may that says to in
the bees one of the stage and I'm gonna
get it blown up painted beautiful right
yeah like in like illegible cursive and
painted watercolors yeah maybe that's
what we start like they just oh yeah so
could I tell you an idea Squarespace
okay look like don't squarespace.com
tchotchke knickknacks calm yeah
dirty catch gonna be dealt like I don't
talk to me till I've had my coffee or
after that either yeah yeah yeah
great okay with the business business
meeting later now speaking of business
we're gonna venture into a little bit of
world business news USA Gymnastics
declares bankruptcy in the wake of sex
abuse scandal a lawyer for the 180
victims said the move will block their
efforts to learn who knew about Larry
Nasser's criminal oh how convenient
yes so facing a mountain of lawsuits
over the Larry Nasser sexual abuse
scandal USA Gymnastics filed for
bankruptcy on Wednesday the beleaguered
organization has been beset by financial
struggles and leadership leadership
turnover as it has sought to contain a
scandal sparked by Nasser the longtime
teen doctor accused of molesting
hundreds of young women and girls USA
Gymnastics ed is currently facing 100
lawsuits representing more than 350 Nasr
victims around the country by filing for
breakup see the organization is able to
put a hold on all litigation including
ongoing discovery and depositions of key
figures multiple sources told NBC News
Katherine Carson who was recently
elected chair of the USA Gymnastics
Board of Directors said the cases will
be consolidated before a bankruptcy
judge a move that will allow the
organization to resolve claims more
quickly
well she said I'm just thinking about
like it's really sad sorry but I'm just
thinking about the biker thing and I'm
laughing cuz of that now because it okay
oh yeah yeah yeah like cuz you're just
thinking that like great athletes we're
absolutely thinking about we're in dark
times we have to laugh because this
story is so [ __ ] so [ __ ] up this is
just another leg
[ __ ] death and it's like at this point
it's past the point in return like the
person who's in place now who's gonna
take all the brunt of this this woman
Catherine Carson like wasn't around for
the abuse right though and so she said
we owe it to the survivors to resolve
fully and finally claims based on the
horrific acts of the past and through
this process seeks to expedite
resolution and help them move forward
like I'm sure her heart is in the right
place
assuming she wasn't around during this
time she ain't got promoted from the
inside but it's like they can't handle
the scope of this it's Larry's in jail
like the people who need to pay our God
here's the thing in the words of my
friend Taylor Swift there's a special
place in hell for women who don't
support other women but there is truly a
special place in hell for like people
who like know about abuse for adults who
don't particularly like they are in the
same dorm room in hell as like Hitler
like they are the worst people in the
world I hope that their souls are being
burned by the pizza out but they're
still alive it's just they're not part
of the USA Gymnastics organization
anywhere and it's like they didn't
protect these kids no like but the
lawsuits aren't against them because
they're coming for USA Gymnastics right
I'm sure that's where the money is and
that's the organization that [ __ ] them
over these people was just a job now
that they don't have the job like
they're technically out of the brain
they're just like countries and you
can't get blood from a stone
if literally Jim NASA's like well we've
literally have no money you have no
money and what does this mean for the
USA gymnastics team like rap Mon vials
are they like are they private sponsors
and stuff so he'll be able to I mean I
don't think like okay I'll start a
GoFundMe we're gonna make sure that
those girls make it to Tokyo of course I
can go to $100 those girls will make it
to Tokyo imagine like them suffering
because of this no that would be the
real tragedy
poetic injustice yeah yeah USA
Gymnastics they need to overhaul
overhaul or just like a new US Asian and
when it like genetics Team USA yeah but
like that's completely new look that's a
startup that has good moral values but
studies fault [ __ ] you know name yeah
for uneven bar [ __ ] yeah like that
and then every they just wear like
leather like maybe like they wear biker
out of it like they have leather jackets
that have flames with like us and also
span next so it's a combination of both
exactly bikers and AIDS and you know
what we're winning gold baby
we're winning goal oh yeah we have the
heart we do and the talent of course of
course are in the Olympics like there's
so many politics literally and
figuratively it's like not even about
talent but it like I think it there's
all of that but the cream always rises
like that I think some of the USA
Gymnastics mic girls are just on a whole
other level then it's it's it's us in
Romania the only people who really work
probably longer hours in jail mania is
the [ __ ] [ __ ] from Romania if you
were gonna do any sport in the Olympics
what would you do summer ping-pong Oh
summer summer but like obviously if I
want to become like do I have to put in
the work now um maybe a touch right okay
so like obviously I would want to be the
most famous ones are the gymnastics gals
and they make the most money afterwards
and they go on the tour of the Kellogg's
yeah so I would say that but they really
also put in the most physical effort so
I might be better off in something a
little bit more low-key like archery
okay yes good hand on what about you
right um well probably just because I'm
built like an ox I would probably end up
doing like the shop but you know I mean
like I was on the track and field team
is changeable yeah yeah I would be on
the track and field team but the funny
thing is is like I can't run a block you
know would I be the anchor I could be
well no I would not do any dead sprint
I'm just saying I'd literally be the one
like big girl on the squad that would
just throw stuff yeah it's like that big
heavy ball that she did and yelled Oh
what I played soccer I like
competitively for a while I would always
do the throw ins you know that's when
you look at sidelines because I can just
locate my shoulders and literally it was
probably like a skin was saying I can
literally lift my arms back so far and I
would throw the ball to the other side
of the field and they never saw what
position do I started it forward and
then as I developed I got chunkier I
went forward and then even builder and
then I was really like so bring these
inner defensive goalies yeah would you
play oh well I would love to meet
gymnast but like I don't know if I have
what it takes yeah so if I'm just there
to be at the Olympics and get on TV
mmm I was gonna say swimmer because then
I can hang out with the men's team yeah
but then I have to be on TV innovating
in a bathing suit
I need a swim cap oh yeah like they make
you grow out all your hair like arm and
armpit while you're training so that you
have more like a tip yeah what's it
called
like 10 with the eye in on the treadmill
incline incline it though it's not
really inclined I guess it's like just
position yeah so and then you shave
right before so it's like you're even
faster than you trained for and I don't
think you could do that angel like you
got you trained as like a like a husky a
second then you you compete as a dolphin
right so is like 105 pounds probably for
them yeah 100 yeah so maybe a little
beach volleyball oh you would thrive but
you're so sure you have to be a maybe I
should stick to the Winter Olympics much
more your vibe honestly I just would
though as its hurling girly very hard
yeah very hard TV host please yeah me
too that's what I want oh yeah I'll host
the digital show for NBC Billy Budd
what's his name had Costas never forget
no very good no but it's like you have
pinkeye like stay home yeah he really
he's also in the television that was so
cheap what a [ __ ] show so choose the
rocks yes I'm so sorry I've been like
literally it's okay it hasn't really
been talking water I have some water
yeah let's all take a drink three the
road the road did it okay
you didn't I'm sorry good oh no no go
home just like you know when you get
that cough and then I'm that person like
in a restaurant it's itchy it's just a
tickle and then people start like
backing away from me and I have to go
like I'm not good dangers like get a
name and it's just like when I have a
cough I'm like I can and everyone's like
look at me I'm like I'm sick [ __ ] off
right but if someone's coughing around
me I'm like you're just comes together
like no serious to that go home and I've
seen the doctor twice for the final
story it's more business
ride-hailing firm lift files for IPO
beating rival uber what's the initial
public offer initial public offering
ride-hailing company public they're
going public lift beat bigger rival uber
in filing for an initial public offering
that will test investor appetite for
high-profile but lost making technology
companies the company which was last
valued at about fifteen billion dollars
did not specify the number of shares it
was selling or the price range for the
offering and a confidential filing with
the SEC the IPO was slated for the first
half of 2019 sources have told Reuters
uber is expected to pursue an IPO next
year that can value it
120 billion while home renting company
Airbnb valued at thirty 1 billion
dollars is also expected to list itself
in 2019 well so I didn't realize that
uber is not public I mean either
and that lift is gonna go first but for
people who live in New York where uber
is so much more prevalent like this is
shocking but it's because I travel so
frequently around the country
lyft is really like the bigger app in
most main cities so like this isn't that
shocking but uber it's kind of like the
cooler one and literally [ __ ] themselves
branding with those ugly pink mustaches
in the beginning they'll be forever be
ingrained in my mind it's the loser
mustache company right and when you is
like he had the Kia Soul that would like
roll-up and then it had a giant
moustache and you're like I don't you're
like yeah
Oh were you looking for Tiffany yeah
she's over there yeah yeah although I've
been riding a lift because you connected
Delta Delta always still like Delta
Gamma yeah I can't grab my anchor up but
uber is worth more it's saying that it
will be probably at 120 million while
lyft is that 15 but what's most
interesting about that article but that
is in what it's saying is that it's
really just a test to see if these kinds
of companies can go public and and it'll
be because grab it of all because
they're not profitable like these
companies uber and lyft make the most
money they pay the drivers nothing still
can't turn a profit Wow Wow where's in
debt everyone's going bankrupt and it's
like the biggest companies in the world
literally my life would be so different
my life is reliant on this technology
they can't make coin the drivers can't
make way neither yeah there's a big
thing that they're trying to fix in New
York right now too is that they're gonna
raise the actual hourly wage for the
uber drivers so they're basically saying
like are you guys willing to pay $70 to
get out to LaGuardia as opposed to $50
like we pay more but then more drivers
like that yeah because that's why you
would suck and that's why sometimes like
morally I think it's better to do lift
or Juno because when you were you know
yes you know it's like the new one oh
yeah it's like been in beta for three
years but they bought get and they okay
what's up yeah it's these really ride
share and they be sharing the ride is it
so right sure no but so here's the thing
the thing is what you know it's better
morally right so it's like sometimes
junot it's like the drivers explained to
me he's like we prefer there's more
customers on uber but I wish they were
on Gino because if you have a $10 ride
Juno will give the driver $8 Hoover will
give them four that's the difference the
differentiating factor for Juno like if
they were on Shark Tank and they were
pitching and Mark was like what's the
difference they say we treat our drivers
better that's right got it okay so it's
like uber it's on but these drivers I
don't know why should I have to pay $70
to go to MGH afk because Hoover doesn't
want to pay their [ __ ] drivers yeah
why don't you give them the proper
Commission and that I can also maintain
my $50 ah and then I'm gonna tip them I
brought always I always take care of my
drivers especially in the long trips
absolutely no and so but what you wind
up paying $70 anyway to get to JFK and I
think the problem is like the way that
these company structure themselves is
like they all auto we're tech company we
automatically want to be Facebook they
hire like a thousand people who sit
around and do nothing and like only
people who were needs to hire our
drivers yeah drivers know and then like
someone to manage the app and like make
updates really like should we get a
company van damme or something HR
marketing you know corporate culture
that my where the money's going need
marketing for uber no you know the most
genius marketing that ruber has on the
back of a bus yep it says hey are you a
cab driver and you're looking to make
more and more than five thousand dollars
a week it's for the drivers yeah I don't
need to know everyone knows what uber is
the drivers we need more drivers drivers
yeah there's enough passengers
I rarely fought the other day I was like
why did I not invent uber I knew I had
that thought in my mind I'm like no this
has literally changed our lives but I
remember when uber came out I never
thought like oh my god this is
incredible it was like finally someone
did this like it wasn't a revolutionary
idea it was just someone finally did it
yeah do you know you're right
honestly I just don't remember life
before uber so I don't remember what it
was like I do you couldn't go get a cab
at four o'clock because they were
changing shifts so as you're true New
Yorkers do you ever take a cab I started
to actually revert back to take actually
out of the airport because it's like in
New York the government hates Buber
because it's taking money away from
taxis right and it they say it causes
congestion so they hate it and they do
everything they can to make us hate it
too and we're starting to work because
it's so [ __ ] hard to get out of the
airport I literally was waiting for our
uber I stuck my big fat hand out and I
got a cab like yeah they're making it
easier for yellow cabs where it's like
wanting you Murr check
in Chicago the uber system is so
integrated with the cabs like you can
get a regular yellow cab and pay for it
on your cell phone so much sure that me
and men were in [ __ ] Chicago and we
got out of a cab and went to a
restaurant and we 20 minutes into the
restaurant we were like did we pay for
that cab no but we had forgotten cuz the
uber was so integrated then we forgot to
pay for the hell yeah that's how much
they work together but in New York it's
polar opposite I had a friend who flew
into LaGuardia the other day she had to
wait there was something because you
know LaGuardia is a [ __ ] show because
are we doing it right now
she waited in the taxi line two hours oh
and you can't get an uber there you have
to take a shuttle to a primer can pick
you but you can get an uber from
LaGuardia so there's you can't oh that's
right that's right I'm like Southwest
Delta I mean I roll is easy Delta was
the first terminal to get read and to
get revamped at LaGuardia so it's the
best one yeah uh yeah also with yellow
cabs you don't like now with uber so
many drivers are so new they don't know
you New York and you like they don't
know what to do but with yellow cabs
like they are still the best route of
the best routes they really know the
city inside it out but they smell so I
think that they've gotten a lot better
I've been in some smelly [ __ ] in the
summer in a cab like well there's air
conditioning that's where we are
conditioning and and I don't like you
that's another TV you guys yeah right we
have your taxpayer dollars sounding
Kinyon Eyewitness News
yeah even it I need to get him on the
show totally ok now I'm gonna take your
questions for you because they're over
congruent or comments people want to
hear from you Krieger
first up when are you permanently moving
to New York that's also a personal
question tomorrow yeah probably sometime
in January in February
I've got to figure out my life ok um
how's your podcast going when is it
going yeah this is like launching like
it's something from SpaceX like we just
keep talking about it and it hasn't come
up so I'm talking with a different
couple different networks so hopefully
trying to get funding behind it because
when I try to do it on my own I realize
this is stupid I should get somebody to
help me with the network what is a
creative premise is that you and Robin
is a you alone right now it's called the
absolutely not podcast ok like and it's
basically a safe space for like women in
their 30s or anybody really I want to
interview people in the industry come
what no I want it to be a spaceship yeah
where we can talk about anything where
we can we start we start bitching about
some stuff during the day and we go
through our absolutely nuts and then you
know we bring it full circle and then
Robin will deftly be on the pocket of
course you need to incitement yeah yeah
where she does like um like the news
with Robin you know there's like with
Howard Stern Show he doesn't use with
Robin well we're gonna do the news with
Rob cute we love Howard but my mom I
love Howard Stern we never listen to
show a day in our lives we just love him
what he stands for
yeah oh really cuz I listen to him all
the time I love Stern we do the car we
don't that's right right so like I don't
even know where drivers the second I
don't know how I would I watch some of
his clips on Instagram like when he
interviewed Khloe Kardashian I just like
loved him I loved that he was on
America's Got Talent and I guess like
weirdly obsessed with him and I don't
know anything about him he's like it's
just scrunch old old man and him like I
just love listening to him like [ __ ] I
was like I think that like he would
maybe like us for sure right okay he's
actually really great and I know some of
the stuff on his show is a little like
the over sexualized stuff it's getting
ornate yeah and I don't I literally will
tune off would that stuff but when he
does interviews they are so interesting
and in-depth I'm a big Howard Stern fan
yeah me too I keep just like talking
about him in the hope so like one of his
interns watches and like shows him yeah
for sure
Sally so last time you were here you're
a friend of Busy Philipps we were
talking aboot Anais I was asking you the
format what you need um
what are your thoughts on busy Jan and
you went to the set when you were in LA
I did
I mean she's coming into her own you
know with any show you gotta like work
out the kinks but it is so great and
she's so naturally like chill and gifted
and like talking to people I think the
show's a success is she having a good
time doing it is she like yeah I say
should she hard overworked well I mean
they you know when any day that you
shoot like two or three shows in a day
is a lot but this that's beautiful it's
a really chill vibe but it's a tiny
little studio so it's like a real
intimate experience how do you know her
we used to go take SoulCycle together
she knows everyone by the way really
who else I don't know how they shot the
first season a queer eye in Atlanta and
we had mutual friends from LA and he
sent me a message just like two summers
ago and he's like hey you're super funny
let's hang out and so we would hang out
and I met all the guys but this is like
and then literally overnight the show
yeah yeah he's a sweetheart he doesn't
oh so he is the reason why you guys
probably found me no from the toasters
everyone was sending me brittany 9-1-1
yeah well but he's the one who retweeted
and is like my girlfriend Heather is
crazy she's putting up this brittany
9-1-1 and honestly i owe him a lot like
it literally kind of totally yeah well
so tell me about the dynamic between the
guys cuz i know there's like a
differently they're a divided because
like tomorrow and bobby i think are like
outsiders we're Antony and JBN and who's
tan tan-tan are like cutie best friends
here's the thing they actually really
all like each other from what I know I
don't think there's any weird divide
okay I know that Bobby spends a lot of
time I think in LA because you know they
all go back and forth yeah and they're
all married it's just right it's a you
know like they're like socialites but
they're all like a nice married guys but
yeah I want to start families like they
have good family Kurama with us on yeah
honestly I don't think there's any
gossip there I'd bring in the hot Goss
but I really genuinely think that
they're all like really great that's a
no and when I met them all in Atlanta
they were so lovely and so cool and I
can't say anything bad about him okay
good guys also all the comments are
about how much people love you and I
just I you should over you know okay
they're friends like you need to know
Heather I love you guys this is so
awesome and I'd feel honored and y'all
keep me young and hip I'm 1332 in March
and I feel like I got to get back to
like you know I was funny in my 20s you
were fun when we went out to the strip
club in Atlanta oh we did it I got drunk
like hardcore we got drunk I was like
really hungover on the plane yeah it was
it was a whole night I took you to the
Clermont lounge a new favorite place
it's the best it's where the older strip
clubs in Atlanta and it just it's a but
literally oldest including the strippers
yeah I mean this it's the kind of place
where you go to see like a woman with a
real body yeah and she might be 65 and
like I just had a presentation and
you're like yes wait that's really
empowering yes it's cuz like in in my
wildest dreams like I could never be a
stripper for so many reasons but one I
just like don't have the physique that
it takes but the Clermont lounge should
kind of change that yeah yeah question
for you when you were here you put out
into the universe about designing women
yes then it came out that they're
bringing it back which would you believe
I manifested on the show manifest
destiny this show perfect this show
makes dream
come true we say [ __ ] GCB brought back
designing women brought back friends
Frank I love GCD I wanted to talk about
this yeah coming that I love if I can't
oh I know I'm going to get on designing
women' but I do a guest star role on GCB
yeah a perfect for it yeah and has
designing women read you know it got
picked up by I think ABC so hopefully
I'm going to go in as a professional
actor and do real auditions do you don't
have a shot like right you want to try
that job yes yes you have yeah like I
have like I mean that's what I am it's
so funny when people are like are you an
influencer I'm like no I'm just a
comedian who puts up on the internet
because I was taking tired of going on
auditions right like you're gonna play
like a dirty one and leg poker I'm like
I gotta can make my own opportunities to
yeah I'm an entrepreneur way oh now you
really are becoming like more of an
influencer in addition to being actress
comedian how has that changed like your
financial here I know see your cup I
mean I do some like very naturally
sponsored posts no yes but I really and
truly I only do it unless I actually
like are to use the product or I like it
you know I mean nobody's like you know
what I'm gonna look right into the
camera
Old Navy you keep sending me jeans but
you know I need to be on a billboard in
Times Square call me you know you're
selling out your Rockstar jeans because
of me
I have to see something about it I'm
sorry dude a partnership at Amazon yeah
and I know that I'm like um mmm what's
the word blank goods when you're like
broken
oh you're broken good I know what I'm
you're on you're like what may be raised
when you're like you're not tarnished
good these are saying tarnished goods no
I don't already because they take here
the row row NYC
Jackie what's the word no I don't know I
need to find it now um I know I'm
spoiled milk weight tarnished goods
yeah it's tarnishing goods it's in our
name what I mean damaged wow wow we were
thinking too hard for like I'm like
good roughed up good understanding that
I'm damaged goods and that like everyone
hates me
but it really seems like Miss marvellous
miss Mazal Amazon went out of their way
to work with every influencer except the
one Jewish comedian when you are in New
York do you not I mean it's a girl
everyone's like you have to watch
marvelous today so you have to watch
more of us to say so to you it's a
Jewish comedian oh please
they literally it's like they had to try
so hard to hire so many people who were
in me now I'm not upset because what I'm
not upset but I just think it's
interesting
that's very true I find it interesting
well of all the good guns to you for
champagne for 18 I will push you in
front of a bus [ __ ] I'm a old Navy
jeans down on the side of it that's like
BuzzFeed writing an article the 17
cutest King Charles Cavaliers that you
have to follow on Instagram just to
leave on video and then Instagram jobs
on there with 100 followers so my joke
is 7006 Grimm polymers and he literally
puts up the most premium content has an
attitude like they wrote the list just
to sum up see because it's the most
random specific list King Charles
Cavaliers in New York City though meme
start with the T yeah I'm like it was so
crazy and stupid everyone is like out
for blood myself included
ok one last question these are just for
now my interview my um what's her name
Barbara Walters questions so obviously
your content is premium right your
Instagram story is poppin at all times
and you're very unfiltered is there
anything that you won't post you ever
like question like should I go on this
rant with like I felt bad about posting
about the hotel thing because I never
want to shame brands and like disparage
a business yeah I never want you because
there's people who are working but I was
just like this is out of control you
know what it is as I think that I've
been so genuine about [ __ ] like
obviously I try and find the glass
half-full like you know the arc of my
Instagram story today is that like
whatever we're moving on up stay humble
I just want people I don't know no I
never really filter anything you know I
think I'm a joyful person and positive
there's I think comedians who come from
kind of like a dark negative place and I
think I'm like look we're in this shitty
situation but we're living our best life
at the same time I couldn't agree more
and yes you feeling on this like well
you're like a real comedian but like I
have like always felt weird about
calling my
comedian because I feel like especially
tour right now female comedians but in
general like they're always like on like
it's ignored in the dressing room it's
like you're offstage and they're just
like but yeah and I don't want to be
like that I find that annoying
do you agree um yes yes I do but also I
think it's just like our personalities I
mean look I'm really genuinely myself
and you're a funny person not also just
like a good comic who can write good
jokes
Oh - yeah oh I appreciate that right
back at you yeah I mean we're just like
funny people right it is what it is I
know but it's like you feel like
comedian has a stigma because it's like
right I mean I technically am probably
like shitty for saying that like I'm a
comedian cuz I'm not doing a stand-up
tour right now but it's right I mean you
write scripts you do all I'm doing all
I'm doing the most and the least at the
same damn time
honestly that couldn't be true yeah do
you thing on your great um no no should
I it's bad if I feel guilty now about
posting about how she they wronged you
but honestly like if you need my five
hundred dollars right it's like that if
you like pain and you got what you paid
for it like that's what you get for
going a cheap hotel but you paid the
rate of like not I think we rate of what
you'd pay it like a nice hotel so at the
very least they can just match the price
that it's actually worth no guilt no I
always feel weird like I will I won't
filter but like when it comes to
disparaging like a local business like
I'll be like I'll think about it like
hmm do I really want to do that and it's
only when they like push me to the edge
which is exactly what happened to you
like El Molino oh my god I went into El
Molino three times all different
locations first time horrible experience
second time horrible experience third
time they pushed me to the edge with the
[ __ ] mushrooms right and I had to
talk about it yeah so it's like when you
provoke me right you get what you pay
for and I think it'd be different if I
was one of those people I've never like
I have literally worked every service
industry right that is why I have no
tolerance for I just don't have you
already when hospitality is bad
yep you know what cuz I've always found
a yes in every situation when I worked
you know and I had some me screaming in
my face about some customers always
right the customer is always right
especially if there's like stains all
right
the customer's always right especially
when they have photo evidence I I think
I need to see a therapist about it I
think you do too and maybe like a throat
someone who temple says both yeah one
last thing we need to talk about because
we would be remiss in just didn't nina
Garten ha oh my god Ben's favorite thing
he watches video every night before his
bed I think he's in love weights like
you but like only as Ina Garten yeah if
he saw you in your regular hair he'd be
like not interested right ina yeah he's
there it's very um sexual for a lot of
people as well cuz it's like the food
thing yes so I'm obsessed with her and
the funny thing is like I'm the worst
cook in America literally my mom is like
an incredible chef I can't even like
make toast you know it's a morning toast
but I would burn it I would burn I don't
mean sorry I smell toast so I found the
wig and problem you know I was just like
this when I put it on it was just like
that moment in octave it was literally
putting on a wedding dress where I was
like this is it this is the old one I
was like in tears and then I came down
the stairs and my mom was like wow you
have a very round face she was like it
just all came together I just love her
also I did not know that that was her
name for the longest time and my mom has
all her cookbooks I thought it was
Barefoot Contessa in her garden
yeah no I just thought you spotted with
a team it's Chuck it's too weird yeah
look your bears up there right like
she's barefoot in the garden yeah it's
like she was meant to play this role I
thought her name was like Cheryl I had
no idea that every day was fine a garden
this your teaching place dishrag on your
shoulder might have been my favorite
part it's really the details yeah and I
love it that she's always like I mean
really and truly no hate no Jayde but
you know she's like this is such an easy
recipe for now and it has her made
butter yeah creme fraiche straight from
you know it's a baldies you're like when
you think out of touch yeah I think I'm
a gardener Yeah right like no clue that
there are people like who literally
can't put food on the table like from
McDonald's right load your homemade
creme fraiche I like and my mom cooks
the salt and my mom's even like she
cooks with so much salt like my mom is
you know loves a salt situation but
she's like cut the salt my house like
it's a heavily there's a lot of Himalaya
I'm worried about her blood sugar she do
you did anyone from her team reach out
to you after know a couple people from
Food Network they're like oh my god we
showed her me in the office but nobody
nobody's reached out she doesn't like
[ __ ] like that like do you know that
Instagram account in the garden insta
garden people shop her head everywhere
it's
so funny and cute it's really looking
how Maj they're obsessed with her yeah
and she's blocked them she does not like
being spoken about in any way that
doesn't regard her food that's so you
know so she's definitely I'm not telling
me yeah maybe else here like chip
Rihanna's lady and it's so funny cause
people who do that I'd do it for the
love of ina yeah it's all out of luck
I'm a good place she is the queen in her
denim shirts and she just killed him
bubbly and she loves Geoffrey and she
never knows where Jeffrey's coming from
she's always like Oh Geoffrey you know
he's running around yeah he didn't
literally be like on a you know on a
cruise to the Caribbean just like he'll
be home in 45 minutes and he brings her
like fresh daisies and like a bottle of
caviar and her niece Phoebe is her name
is yeah I don't see what she's up to I
feel like she's a toaster first sure
Phoebe yeah baby can you look it out
yeah I feel like everyone just
constantly like embark bombarding Phoebe
for like access to Hina I mean she's
just cuz I feel like you're either ina
strong or not yes like honestly I never
had much interest until you came along
Olivia's been obsessed with her whole
huh I mean she could [ __ ] you know what
when you watch her show one it's just
the mood the music everything about that
show is flawless I know what it was that
you said at the end I made then left
welcome to the Hamptons so are you gonna
make more videos yes we're gonna make
some videos this weekend okay oh don't
you worry and then is like the pressure
is on for next year for Halloween do you
have any ideas yet are you feeling the
pressure
honestly I know I mean I literally one
Halloween this year I'm gonna have to be
inspired Yeah right
and I literally came up with the costume
no joke 30 minutes before Wow that's how
I do my best work yes letting you know I
agreed that the best ideas come from
like literally laughing yeah also do you
all watch the Food Network no yeah of
course I cannot stand the Pioneer Woman
white people looking love her know
everything she's Lockard I know but I
can't with the Pioneer Woman everything
she makes I go I would not eat it yeah
well no it's I can't judge on based on
that because I literally like my palate
it's grilled chicken to french fries and
they're not making that on the Food
Network right so I'm really watching the
Food Network for like the glam the glitz
like just the colors so the fact that I
couldn't eat her food it's like that's
our exclusive menu
that or not but sometimes you're right
actually now that I think about it she
made like a goat cheese sandwich with
with like ham it was weird
that's like Antony making a grapefruit
avocado salad for an ascot
she's southern so like I always just
attributed it to be like oh that's what
people in the South eat but maybe not
know she's not in the South she's in
like Wyoming oh isn't she I don't know I
don't what doesn't know I just I can't
about you know who I love who's southern
you need to watch Trisha Trisha Yearwood
yeah the guards
she is a clean and she's a big dominar
as a Food Network Star than she was as a
singer what yeah she's so great and stop
smoking but she like has these cute
little like you know funny one-liners
and then they always like pray before
the meal I'm just like yeah never watch
did you ever watch the Ayesha curry show
I didn't I did not like it like a
cooking channel or Cooking Channel oh I
don't [ __ ] with that either it's like
they put all the low-level talent there
yeah and I'm sure they were testing to
maybe see if she was Food Network
material because she like cooks on
Instagram and I guess that makes you a
she's horrible she is but like the show
was really bothered I mean it's like
Steph had to come on every show
contractually for ten seconds
yeah and honestly I just I didn't like
it at all yeah oh wait I thought one of
the stories was gonna be Sandra oh and
Andy Samberg host yeah and then I got I
got to shine I only wanted to talk about
it cuz I thought like what about bus
hosting the Golden Globes I'm here for
it I think we would be good I don't even
know if I would want to like to feign
interest in those things like I can't
and it's a golden globe so it's like
Sandra oh yes I love Stan Berg's
together weird mix and I think it's
great that Sandra Oh is doing it
especially cos last year she made
history during award season it's like
the first Asian women to win for
Supporting Actress something so great
and like she is a pioneer woman and she
should be there but like I really don't
like Andy Samberg and I feel like he's
the perfect example of a person who has
really gotten to where he is because
he's a straight white man and I don't
like that like I don't think he's funny
or talented really at all as a as a
writer I think just something he's
written is super funny but be famous
himself yeah well I just don't
understand I don't understand the
connection like dude what's that
chemistry gonna be like if we're gonna
have a good James Franco you know Anne
Hathaway moment and I feel like Golden
Globes is usually
not that out of touch like when they did
Amy Amy Poehler Tina Fey like that's
great will felt like this is odd
it's just an odd mix but I would love to
see them both individually but I don't
understand the togetherness maybe
standards gonna come out and just throw
it like we don't realize that she's a
full community yes right cuz she's only
been in dramatic roles so I think she's
you might enterprise to certain she's
only been a pleasure sir no just regular
certain right oh yeah well she's in a
hospital you know do you know that I
never watch grace me neither you're in
good company I never watch One Tree Hill
either neither or never watched one
grace no oh I love Will and Grace oh but
they will and grace is my friends oh
really
it's Seinfeld I'm outside though Will
and Grace I'm not a friends what's the
other maybe Frasier okay I don't watch
any of the shows if it has a laugh track
I can't watch it yeah well let's just
forgot sighs no I did the greatest show
of all time you should get into it okay
Joe I'm gonna get into it it's on Hulu I
feel like you guys are always up with
like the good shows we are
I just want of taste yeah touch makers
I'm more like Curb Your Enthusiasm
Marissa develop 30 or so 30 I'm so 30
rock and we are so 30 wrong and we were
actually at 30 record I like two days
ago for a meeting and we were in the
elevator people thought we were so crazy
we were just like show it's very nice to
do a to do my show and sing that song or
make a Liz Lemon reference when it rains
it pours it's what it's like why are you
wearing a tux it's after 6:00 p.m. what
do you think I have a farmer that's JEP
like that will be on the Italian
stallions grave is Alec Baldwin's quote
as Jack Donaghy it's so funny because I
[ __ ] hate Alec Baldwin but I love
Jack Donaghy Jack Donaghy's every
everything dream man like I just love
him and I think it was actually I'm
specifically attracted to Alec Baldwin a
person I have said it once before and
I'll say it again like I think Alec
Baldwin's really hot and he's just
saying your issues are like starting to
get a little out of hand I don't mean
that I handed him I take that first I
actually really love him like secretly
in shame though cuz he like called his
daughter a pig and like it's a crazy
these people up for parking oh yeah and
he just got arrested when like a mansion
in are taken on the street like it
wasn't even a real parking spot it was
public property yeah it was like what's
it called
yeah reverse me yeah yeah who's moving
his car and he usually has two
door man like holes and in the spot and
because it's free part it like right if
you're rich I played in a garage yeah
yeah yeah if you're pretty on the street
it's like because you can't afford the
garage right so it's like you can't
afford the garage really I'm 30 rock six
seasons when you want every Emmy please
and then his doorman stands outside and
says oh no you can't take the spot but
this one guy the doorman left first Ike
and the guy got the spot at Baldwin
punch him in the face I'm unwell and the
media doesn't cover it it's crazy he
gets special treatment obviously though
I Jeff used to make it I mean Jeff
drives in the city and he like turns
into a whole nother person fan is crazy
but the windows are off you know to me
like if anybody actually roll down the
window jumper by coaster I'm sorry
solutely take this like again
passive-aggressive me yeah he could
never actually find someone that is me
to a tee yeah and then I was driving I
had to drive his car once and I got
stuck behind like some parade and I
literally called Jeff I was like I get
it now I get why you're a psychopath
yeah you become a crazy [ __ ] if
you drive yesterday and I I don't get
carsick and when Jeff drives I literally
am so nauseous and I just have to sit
there and close my eyes I'm sorry it's
okay you know what and these are being
driven at least I'm begging driver
that's so true and it's not a smelly
Oberg or cab yeah I got on the subway
that's a great way ladies and gentlemen
it has been an absolute pleasure hanging
out with you this morning
Thank You Heather for joining us if you
guys want to keep up with the
shenanigans and see if anything happens
with the row follow Heather on insert on
Heather K McMahon yes right we'll post
it on the tow so you'll be able to find
it she's a hoot and a half we love you
guys we'll see you tomorrow any no
guests tomorrow it's a regular Friday to
wrap up the week our first full week
together probably in four or five months
four or five week Oh together yeah
perhaps all right you guys love you
you